[inaudible]
good morning.
It's a pleasure to be here this morning.
I've got to ask your indulgence on
two things. It's allergy season.
So I have a real hard time during this
time of the year speaking and to, uh,
most of the speaking I do when I walk
up to the podium is very technical.
It deals with cyber crime
and identity theft, forgery,
embezzlement and things of that nature.
I don't often talk about my life,
but Google has asked me today,
do something that different and
talk a little bit about my life.
So I will do that.
And then at the end of course I'll take
questions and those questions can be
about any subject matter that
you like to ask. As you know,
I've had a lot of people tell my story.
I had a great movie director
write a film about my life.
I had a great Broadway musical team,
make a Tony Award winning
Broadway musical about my life,
had a popular television show on TV,
white collar for four years
curtain around my life.
And most of those very creative people
have actually never met me personally,
but they've enjoyed telling my
story from their point of view.
So I thought it would take a few minutes
this morning and actually tell you the
story from my point of view.
I was raised just north of New York
City in Westchester County, New York.
I was actually one of four
children in the family,
the so called middle child or the form.
I was educated there by the Christian
brothers of Ireland in a private Catholic
school called Iona where I went to
school from kindergarten to high school.
By the time I had reached the
age of 16 in the 10th grade,
my parents after 22 years of marriage
one day decided to get a divorce.
Unlike most divorces where the children
were usually the first to know.
My parents were very good
about keeping that a secret.
I remember being in the 10th grade when
the father walked in the classroom one
afternoon,
asked the brother to excuse me from class.
When I came out in the hallway,
the father handed me my books and told
me that one of the brothers would drive
me to the county seat in white plains,
New York,
where I would meet my parents and
they would explain what was going on.
I remembered the brother dropped me at
the steps of a big stone building and
told me to go on up the
steps in my parents would be
waiting for me in the lobby.
I remember climbing the steps,
seeing a sign on the building
that said family court,
but I really didn't understand what
that meant. When I arrived in the lobby,
my parents were not there,
but I was ushered into the back of an
immense courtroom where my parents were
standing before a judge.
I couldn't hear what the judge was
saying nor my parents' response,
but eventually the judge saw me at the
back of the room and motioned me to
approach the bench, so I walked
up to stand in between my parents.
I remember distinctly that
the judge never looked at me.
He never acknowledged
I was standing there.
He simply read from his papers and said
that my parents were getting a divorce
and because I was 16 years of age,
I would need to tell the court
which parent I chose to live with.
I started to cry,
so I turned and ran out of the courtroom,
Judge Call for a 10 minute recess,
but by the time my parents got outside,
I was gone.
My mother never saw me again for about
seven years until I was a young adult.
Contrary to the movie,
my father never saw me wherever it spoke
to me again in the mid 1960s running
away, it was very popular
thing for young people.
A lot of them got caught up in
Haight Ashbury, the hippie scene,
that drug scene instead, I
took a few, belongs in my home,
packed them in a bag or did what was in
the new haven and Hartford railroad for
the short train ride down to grand
central terminal in New York.
My father did own the
stationery store in Manhattan.
It was located on the corner of
40th and Madison. Like all of us.
We had to work in that store.
So from the time I was about 13 I made
deliveries from my dad in the summer on a
bike.
I knew the city very well.
So naturally I started looking
for the same type of work.
There were a lot of signs on the windows
stock boy delivery boy part time.
I'd walk in and apply. So tell
me young man, how old are you?
16 how far did you go in high
school? 10th Grade, I'll hire you.
And I went to work for a small
amount of money, a few hours a day.
But as soon realized I couldn't
support myself on that amount of money.
I also realized as long as people
believed I was 16 years old,
they weren't going to pay me any more
money. At 16 I was six foot tall.
I've always had a little gray hair.
My friends in school used to say that
once a week when we dressed in a suit for
mass, I look more like a teacher. So I
decided to lie about my age in New York.
We had a driver's license at 16 back then.
It didn't have a photo on it,
just an IBM card. So I altered
one digit and my date of birth,
I was actually born in April
of 1948 but I dropped the four,
converted it to a three and
that made me 26 years old.
I walked around applying
for the same type of work.
People gave me a little more money,
few more hours,
but even then it was very
difficult to make ends meet.
One of the few things I had taken
when I left home was a checkbook.
I had money from work on the summers.
I had some money in that checking account.
So every so often I would write
a check to supplement my income.
$20 $25 the funds were there,
the checks were good,
but it was my friends, my peers who
would constantly say to me, you know,
you're the only guy. No walks into
a bank in the middle of Manhattan.
You have no account there you don't know
is so you talked to somebody behind a
desk and they okay or check, oh
my checks are good. You have it.
If I walked in there, they wouldn't
touch my cheque. You walk in there,
they don't bat an eye.
I,
years later reporters would write and
speculate and say that that was my
upbringing, mannerisms, dress,
appearance, speech, whatever it was.
It was very easy to do. So
consequently, when the money right now,
I kept writing those checks. Of
course, the checks started to balance.
Please started looking
for me as a runaway,
so I thought maybe it was a good time
to start thinking about leaving New York
City, but I was quite apprehensive
about going to Chicago or Miami,
one that if they cash in New York,
check on a New York driver's license
in Miami as quickly as they did in
Manhattan. I was walking at
42nd street when afternoon,
about five o'clock in the evening, 16
years old, pondering all of these things.
When I started to approach the front
door of an old hotel that used to be,
they're called the Commodore
Hotel now the Grand Hyatt,
just as I was about to get to the front
door of the hotel out stepped in eastern
airline flight crew onto the sidewalk.
I couldn't help but notice the captain
and the copilot, the flight engineer,
about three or four flight attendants
dragging their bags to the curb to load
them in the van to take them to
the airport as they loaded the van.
I thought to myself, that's
it. I could pose as a pilot,
I could travel all over
the world for free.
I probably could get just about anybody
anywhere to cash a check for me.
So I walked up the street a
little further to 42nd and park.
I went to cross over,
I heard a huge helicopter.
So I looked up and there was New York
Airways landing on the roof for the Pan Am
building Pan Am the nation's flag carrier.
The airline that flew around the world.
I thought, what a perfect airline to use.
So the next day I placed a phone call
to the executive corporate offices,
a pan n. I remember distinctly
when the phone was ringing,
I had absolutely no idea what I was going
to say when they answered Panamerican
Airlines. Good morning. Going to help
you now. Yes ma'am. I'd like to. Um,
I'd like to speak to somebody
in the purchasing department
purchasing one moment
and the clerk came on and see us and maybe
can help me. My name is, uh, John Black.
I'm a copilot with the company
based out of San Francisco.
Been with the company about seven years,
but never had anything like this come
up before. But what's the problem? Well,
we flew at chip in here yesterday.
We're going out later today. I,
yesterday I sent in my uniform out
through the hotel to have it dry clean.
Now the hotel and the cleaners
said they can't find it. Yeah,
I'm with a flight and about four hours,
new uniform. And you have a spare uniform?
Certainly back home in San Francisco,
but I never get it here at
the time from my flight.
I do understand this will cost you
the price of uniform, not the company,
but I understand. Hold on, I'll be
right back. He came back and said,
my supervisor says you need to go down
to the well bill uniform company on Fifth
Avenue. There are supplier, I'll call
them and let them know you're on your way.
Well,
that's exactly what I wanted to know.
So I went down to the well bill uniform
company, Little Fella, Mr Rosen,
me out in the uniform, that black
Gabardine three gold stripes on the arm.
I certainly looked old enough to be
the pilot when he was all done. I said,
how much do owe you but the
uniforms? $286 said, no problem.
I'll write you a check. No,
we can't take any checks.
Oh well then I'll um, I'll just pay
you cash and we can't accept cash.
You need to fill out this computer card.
Then it needs boxes.
Put your employee number.
Then we build this back on the uniform
allowance comes out of the annex pain and
paycheck, but that's even
better. Go ahead and do that.
New York had two airports,
Laguardia and Kennedy.
Laguardia was 20 minutes from Manhattan.
Kennedy was 50 naturally Laguardia
being the closer of the two.
That's where I went.
I spent most of the morning walking
around Laguardia in the uniform,
trying to figure out,
now that I had this uniform,
how the hell do you get on these planes?
I got a little hungry.
So about lunch time I walked into the
luncheonette and the terminal sat down
with the counter on the stool in
order to sandwich moments Seder,
a twa crew walked in,
the flight attendant sat in the booth,
but the pilots up at the counter on either
side of me and captain right next to
me. Now back before
deregulation of the airlines,
airline people thought of
themselves as just one big family.
So they didn't hesitate a
moment to talk to each other.
And the captain kind of leaned over.
A young man as Pan Am doing,
doing just fine. Captain, tell me what's
Pan Am doing out here to Laguardia.
Panim doesn't fly into Laguardia.
They only fly into Kennedy. Well,
I picked up on that right
away. Yeah, we came into,
Kennedy had a layover, so I came over
to visit some friends. Matter of fact,
I'm on my way back to
Kennedy now. So tell me, man,
what type of equipment or your arm or
airline people have a lot of jargon for
things and one of them is they never
call a Planar planar and aircraft.
They call it equipment.
And what type of equipment you're I'm in.
What type of plane do you fly back then?
The DCA at seven oh seven of
course I didn't know that.
And I thought type of equipment,
equipment.
Amman is this stool, they must mean
what type of equipment is on the planes.
I've fly. So I thought, well, they've
got the wings, they've got the engine.
It always had a sticker on the engine
who manufactured the engines. So I said,
yeah,
it's General Electric.
All three pilots kind of just stopped
eating and leaned over and he,
Kevin said a really,
what do you fly washing machines?
So I knew I said the wrong
thing out the door. I went,
everybody had an airline ID card,
a plastic laminated card,
much like a driver's license today.
Yet without the ID card,
the uniform was worthless. I went back to
Manhattan, pretty discouraged thinking,
where would I come up with a Pan
American airline corporate ID.
I was sitting in the hotel room. I noticed
a big thick Manhattan yellow pages.
So I pulled them down on the bed,
flipped them open and looked
under the word identification.
There were three or four pages of
companies who made convention badges,
metal badges, plastic badges,
police badge. It's fire badges.
Started to call around and finally
when companies said, listen,
most of those airline ids
manufactured by Polaroid,
three M company B to call one of them
finally got the three m company on the
phone in Manhattan.
You know,
we manufacture paintings identification
system along with a number of other
carriers. How come? So tell you, I'm a
purchasing officer for a major US carrier.
I'm in New York just for the day, or
we're getting ready to expand our routes.
Are a lot of new employees
go to a formal id.
We're very impressed with
this Pam format when that,
if I came by our office
this afternoon briefly,
we could discuss quantity and
price by all means come on by.
So I went by a dressed in a suit and the
sales were up. Opened the book. Yeah,
we do United Braniff national Pan Am Pan
Am we'd like this Pan Am format when if
you have a sample I could bring
back. Sure, I'll be right back.
And he brought me back a five by seven
glossy piece of paper with a picture of
an ID card blown up in the middle of it.
Someone else's picture in the picture.
John Doe for a name and in
boulder I think across the front.
This is a sample only. I said, no,
I'm afraid this one to you and I need
to bring back an actual physical card.
And by the way,
what is all this equipment on the floor?
And we don't just sell these cards. We
sell the system camera laminator. I, oh,
we have to buy all this.
Absolutely. But tell you what,
since we have to buy it all,
why don't we just demonstrate
how it works and use me fine.
I have a say right here.
Take my picture.
I was going down the
elevator studying the card.
It had a blue board or across the top
that a half inch in Pan Am's colored blue
but not a single thing on the card.
Said Pan-am, no logo, no insignia,
no company name. This is a
plastic card, like a credit card.
So you couldn't type on it, couldn't
ride on it, couldn't print on it,
discouraged to put it in my pocket.
Headed back to the hotel
and there was walking back,
I noticed that I had passed the hobby
shop so I turned around and walked back.
Excuse me sir. I've seen,
so a lot of models here.
If some models of commercial
jetliners sure. Over there.
And I bought a model of a Pan
Am seven oh seven cargo jet,
took it back to my room,
open the box through all the parts out,
but they're at the bottom of
the box was a sheet of decals,
one on the model and when
soaked in a glass of water,
the Little Pan and blue globe that we're
doing on the tail of the plastic plane
when perfect up at the top of the plastic
card and the word Pan Am and there's
special styling of graphics,
it would've went on the future.
Lodgement perfect across the top of the
card and it clear decal on the laminated
plastic made a beautiful
identification card.
Pay An amp says they estimate that
between the ages of 16 and 18 I flew more
than a million miles for free board and
more than 260 commercial aircraft and
more than 26 countries around the world.
Pan Am's is,
keep in mind the fact that frank having
Neil didn't impact poses one of our
pilots for a long period of time.
He never once stepped on board
one of our aircraft. That's true.
I never flew on Pan Am because I was
afraid. Someone might say to me, you know,
I'm based in San Francisco,
been out there 16 years.
I don't recall ever meeting you before.
Or someone might say,
you know your ID card,
it's not exactly like my id card.
So instead I flew on everyone else.
If I wanted to go somewhere,
I literally just walked out to the
airport, walked up on the board,
United flight 800 to Chicago.
Then I went downstairs to the
door marked United operations in,
walked in the operations clerk,
hey Pam,
can we do for you if you want to have
to jump seats open on 800 needed it in
Chicago, opened this evening like get
a pink slip pass. I'd give him my id,
right Matt, a pass. I'd walk out,
hand it to the flight attendant.
She'd opened the door to the cockpit
and I'd step in and a captain,
a copilot of flight engineering to seat
behind the captain called the jumpseat
where pilots deadhead on company time
because pilots love to talk shop.
Once you picked up that jargon,
it was the same conversation over and
over and over. So I just step our mod.
Even Gen Bob Davis be run
in Chicago on the taxi out.
Oh is the same questions about how long
you've been with Pan Am been flying
about seven years or position.
You fly right seat,
which is airline terminology for copilot.
What of equipment we on had that one down.
Perfect.
Matter of fact,
whatever they flew,
I didn't fly so no problems with
that and we'd arrive in Chicago.
I'd go by the Pan Am ticket counter,
but just enough to get the attention of
the passenger service Rep. Excuse me,
I haven't laid over here and over a
year it was still at the apartment house
opened downtown, catch crew
bus, low level door, three out.
I go down the Palmer House,
Hilton Walk in and on the corner of the
registration desk was a little sign said
airline cruise. That was a
three ring binder you signed in,
referenced your flight number,
showed your Id. They'd give me a key,
I'd stay two or three days in pain and
would be direct billed from my room and
my meals.
I also could cash a personal check at
the front desk because I was an employee
of the airline.
The airline had a contract with the hotel
and as a courtesy that cash your check.
But then I found out that every airline
honors every other airline employees,
personal check,
actually a reciprocal agreements still
practice today in 2017 so at the San
Francisco airport at Delta
flight attending can walk
up to an American airline
ticket counter show her ID and Cassia
personal checkup to $100 and vice versa.
Of course, when I found that out,
I'd go out to JFK or lax or me,
I'd go to everybody in northeast
and national KLM air gram.
It would take me a good
eight hours stopping at every
counter and every building.
By the time I got all the way
around the other end of the airport,
at least eight hours have gone by.
And what did you have an eight
hours shift change new people.
So I go all the way back around
the other way. As you know,
I went on to impersonate a doctrine,
the Georgia hospital for a while.
I took the bar exams in Louisiana,
passed the bar,
went to work for attorney general pf
Grameen on the Civil Division of the State
Court where I spent about
a year of practicing law in
both the job as the lawyer
and the doctor.
No one ever doubted for a second.
I was not eligible or qualified to do so.
I on my own,
resigned and moved on. Of
course, like any criminal,
sooner or later you get caught and
I was no exception to that rule.
I was actually arrested just once in
my life when I was 21 years old by the
French police in a small town in
southern France called Mum Pa.
The French police were actually arresting
me on an Interpol warrant issued by
the Swedish police who are looking
for me for forgery and Sweden,
but believed that I was living in France
when the French authorities took me
into custody on that warrant.
They realized I had forged
checks all over France.
So they refused to honor the warrant and
Sweden's requests from my extradition.
They later convicted me at forgery
and sent me to French prison.
I served my time and a place
called the maids on Dra,
the house of arrest in a small town,
southern France called Pepin young
Steven Spielberg, tow Barbara Walters.
It was extremely important to me to go
back to that sell to the exact cell he
was in and reconstruct it according to
the log books during his stay there,
he said, to my amazement, that was
a blanket on the floor. No mattress,
a hole in the floor to go to the bathroom,
no plumbing, no electricity. Instead,
according to the log books,
I entered the prison at 198 pounds,
left the prison at 109 pounds.
When sentence was over in France,
I was extradited to Sweden where I was
later convicted of forgery in a Swedish
court of law and essentially the
Swedish penitentiary in Malmo, Sweden.
When my prison term was up in Sweden, US
federal authorities took custody of man,
returned me to the United States,
eventually ignited states
federal judge in Atlanta,
Georgia would sentence me to
12 years in federal prison.
I served four of the 12 years at a
federal prison in Petersburg, Virginia.
When I was 26 years old,
the government offered to take me out
of prison on the condition I go to work
with an agency of the federal government
for the remainder of my sentence or
until my parole had been
satisfactorily completed.
I agreed and was released this year.
I'm celebrating 41 years at the FBI.
I've been at the bureau for more than
four decades. I work out of Washington DC.
I actually make my home in Charleston,
South Carolina,
so every Monday I fly up to Washington
about an hour of flight and I go home on
Thursday evenings.
I live in Charleston with my one
and only wife of 40 plus years,
and my three sons,
my youngest boy graduated from the
University of Beijing in China.
He went on to get his master's
degree there. He reads,
writes and speaks Chinese fluently.
He works for a San Francisco
Gaming Company called Glu
Mobile. He designs gaming,
uh,
games for the Chinese market.
All of his games are in
Chinese and they're in their
fourth generation as mobile
games and devices.
My middle son graduated from
University of Nevada and Las Vegas.
His degree was in business.
He and his wife graduated together
and he and her own a business in South
Carolina and they manage
that business together.
My oldest son graduated from
University of Kansas at k. You,
he went on to Loyola School of law
in Chicago to get his law degree,
passed the bar in Illinois and went
on to make his dad very, very proud.
He's an FBI agent.
He's been in the bureau about 12 years.
He supervises a team that deals with
American citizens, kidnapped overseas.
So their response team that
operates out of Quantico, Virginia.
As many of you know, I had very
little to do with the film. Um,
I would have preferred not to
had a movie made about my life.
I actually raise my three boys in Tulsa,
Oklahoma in the same house for 25 years.
My neighbors had no idea who I was and
I would have preferred it stayed that
way.
But Steven Spielberg told Barbara Walters,
he felt compelled to tell the world
the story, not because of what I did,
but because of what I'd done with my life.
After that,
he loved the redemption side of the story.
We wanted the world to know the story.
So in the end, my family and I were very
pleased with the outcome of the film,
but we thought in a couple of years I
would all be forgotten and move on with
our life. I never dreamed
that. Catch me, if you can,
we go on to earn more than a billion
dollars for dreamworks and be shown over
and over literally every week on Hbo and
TV and then become a Broadway musical
and a TV show. So consequently, every
Monday morning when I come to work,
I have emails.
They come from all over the world.
Someone who's seeing the movie for first
time watching the play at a community
theater or a high school somewhere
and they feel compelled to write,
and of course they come from people
literally as young as eight years old,
sending those emails to people as old
as 80 most people assume I'll never read
those emails or see those emails,
but they feel compelled to write and
they want to make a statement. Some say,
you know, you are brilliant.
You are an absolute genius.
I was neither. I was just a
child, had been brilliant.
Had it been a genius,
I don't know that I would've found it
necessary to break the law in order to
just simply survive.
And while I know that people
are fascinated by what I
did some 50 years ago as a
teenage boy, I've always looked upon
what I did is something that was immoral,
illegal,
unethical,
and a burden I live with literally every
single day of my life and will until my
death. There are many who
write and say, well, you know,
you were certainly gifted that it was.
I was one of those few children and I
got to go up in the world with the Daddy.
Now the world is,
the world is full of fathers,
but there are very few men worthy of
being called daddy by their child.
I had a daddy loved his children
more than you love life itself.
Steven Spielberg, tow Barbara Walters
and mirror research frank shoes. Now,
without having met frank,
I couldn't help but put his father in
the film through the likes of Christopher
Walken. My father was a man who had four
children, three boys and a daughter.
Every night at bedtime,
he'd walk into your room.
He was six three he would drop down
on one knee, kiss you on the cheek,
pull the cover up,
and he put his lip up on your ear lobe
and it whisper deep interior, I love you.
I love you very much.
He never ever missed a night.
As I grew older, I sometimes
fell asleep before he got home,
but always woke up the next morning,
knew he had been back at my bedside.
Years later, my older brother
joined me in my room temporarily.
He was in the Marine Corps.
He was six [inaudible] four he
played semipro football for Buffalo,
but my father would walk around
to his bed, hug him, kiss him,
whispering in his area. He
loved them. When I was 16
years old, I was just a child.
All 16 year olds are just children,
much as we'd like them to be adults,
they're just children
and like all children,
they need their mother and
they need their father.
All children need their
mother and their father.
All children are entitled to their mother
and their father and though it is not
popular to say so divorce is a very
devastating thing for a child to deal with
and then have to deal with the
rest of their natural life. For me,
a complete stranger, a judge told me I
had to choose one parent over the other.
That was a choice of 16 year old
boy could not make. So I rang.
How could I tell you
my life was glamorous.
I cried myself to sleep till I was
19 years old. I spent every birthday,
Christmas,
mother's Day,
Father's day in a hotel room somewhere
in the world where people didn't speak my
language,
the only people that associated with me
where people who believe me to be their
peer 10 years older than I actually was.
I never got to go to his senior prom,
high school football game.
Share a relationship
with someone my own age.
I always knew I'd get caught.
Only a fool would think otherwise.
The last sometimes sleeps with the law.
Never dies.
I was caught.
I went to some very bad places.
My boys have grown up asking their mother,
why is it the dead gets up in the middle
of the night and goes down the TV room
cause you know he didn't turn the TV on.
He just sits there all night as,
because there are things you can forget
things you're not meant to forget what I
was sitting in that pitch
black cell in France.
My father 57 was climbing the subway
stairs in New York as he did every day.
He was in great physical shape.
He just happened to trip.
He reached his arm to break his fall.
He slipped, hit his head on a railing,
laying it at the bottom of the step.
He was dead. I didn't know he was dead.
I was thinking about them,
how much I couldn't wait to
see him, hold him, hug him,
kiss him, tell him how sorry I was, but
I never got the opportunity to do that.
I was very fortunate because I was raised
in a great country where everyone gets
a second chance.
I owe my country 800 times more than I
can ever repay it over these past four
decades.
That is why I'm at the FBI today.
32 years after the federal court
order expired requiring me to do so.
I have turned down three pardons from
three sitting presidents of the United
States because I do not believe no will
I ever believe that a piece of paper,
we'll excuse my actions. That
only in the end my actions. Well,
40 plus years ago on an undercover
assignment in Houston, Texas,
I met my wife when the
assignment was over.
I broke protocol to tell
her who I really was.
I didn't have a dime to my name,
but I eventually asked her to marry
me against the wishes of her parents.
She did, and I could sit up here
and tell you that I was born again.
I saw the light prison rehabilitated me,
but the truth is God gave me a wife.
She gave me three beautiful children.
She gave me a family
and she changed my life.
She and she alone.
Everything I have,
everything I've achieved,
who I am today.
It's because of the love of a woman and
the respect three boys have for their
father.
Something I would never ever jeopardize.
There comes a time in all of our lifetime,
we grow older and eventually
if we're fortunate enough,
we have children and
as every parent knows,
whether your child is three
months old or 38 years old,
when you lay your head
on a pillow at night,
you're just about to close your eyes.
The last thing you think about,
last thing you worry about
are your children. So if
you still have your mother,
you still have your father, you
give him a hug, you give him a kiss,
you're telling me you love them while you
can. And to those men in the audience,
both young and old,
I would remind you what it truly is to
actually be a man has absolutely nothing
to do with money, achievements, skills,
complements degrees,
professions, physicians,
a real man loves his wife.
A real man is faithful to his wife and
real mat next to God and his country.
Put his wife and his children as the
most important thing in his life.
Steven Spielberg made a wonderful film,
but I've done nothing greater,
nothing more rewarding,
nothing more worthwhile,
nothing makes actually brought me
more peace, more joy, more happiness,
more content in my life than simply
being a good husband, a good father,
and what I strive to be every
day of my life. A Great Daddy.
God bless you and thanks
for coming this morning.
[inaudible] we have
bunch of questions, both a
from the audience as well
as some people have sent in.
So we'll take some questions.
I'll be happy. Good answer.
Do you have any advice for Googlers
who are feeling imposter syndrome,
the insecure feeling that they're
not nearly as good at their jobs,
at their job is their
colleagues believe they are?
And how did you stay confident or did you,
when you knew you were,
you were in an imposter?
You know, people always say
to me, you know, you are
brilliant. You are a genius. No,
I was an adolescent and that
was why I was successful.
I was so young that I had no fear of
being caught. I was so young then.
I didn't think about consequences.
Everything I did was not premeditated.
Everything was done by
opportunity or by chance. So if,
in fact I was standing out in front of
a bank in Manhattan with a $500 check,
there was never a plan.
I didn't say to myself,
I'm going in cash check. If
they say this, I'll do this.
If they do this,
I'll do that.
I just went in and did it and I felt
that there was nothing I couldn't do.
I had tremendous confidence in myself,
but everything was for a reason.
So I saw that airline crew,
I never dreamed about getting on planes
or staying in hotels around the world
for free. All I saw was a
uniform and said to myself,
if it had that uniform on
and I walked in a bank,
it would be a lot easier to cash a check.
Then me walking in is just some young kid.
So the whole thing was to
get a uniform and do that.
But then I quickly realized
the power of that uniform,
how it turned from night today.
No one ever said no.
When I walked in to cash a check,
even though there was no bank
account there or anything else,
all they saw was the uniform didn't
see me and I realized very early on the
power of that uniform and then I realized
I had gone to the TWA ticket counter
just like he showed in the movie.
I was going to purchase an airline
ticket and the ticket agents said to me,
are you writing for free? Are you buying
the ticket? And I said, riding for free.
Yeah, you are on the jumpseat.
And I learned about the jump seat.
So then I flew around the world for
free. Everything I did, I did. By chance,
I moved into an apartment
complex in Atlanta.
I said I was a doctor because I didn't
want to write down airline pilot.
They were looking for me with that
airline pilot. So I said it was a doctor.
I said pediatrician,
because it was a singles complex and there
were only single people living there.
And then I met a doctor who lived there
and then he took me up to the hospital
and I met people.
So I ended up at the hospital.
I dated a flight attendant who's father
was the attorney general in Louisiana.
I had told her that I had
gone to law school, but I
never practiced law. Instead,
I wanted it to be a pilot and
got furloughed from the airline.
So she introduced me to
her dad and I went to work.
Everything was all these opportunities,
but always a confidence that I could
pull it off in that that became, uh,
just from age.
But if you believe that you're good at
what you do and you strive to be good at
what you do, you don't need to
worry about what other people think.
You need to be able to understand that
you have your own confidence that you can
do whatever it is you're required
to do and other people will see that
confidence in you.
The minute you start doubting yourself,
other people will see that,
that you're doubting yourself and that
becomes a weakness in your personality.
So you always want to be confident in
everything you do that you can do it,
you can get it done, you'll find
a way to get it. I get it done.
Obviously technology has evolved quite
a bit since you were going around and
things like that.
Would somebody be able to accomplish
something similar today even with all of
the technical advancements?
Yeah. You know, I get asked that a
lot, actually. It's sorry to say,
but 4,000 times easier
today than when I did it.
A technology breach crime,
and it always has and it always will and
there will always be people willing to
use technology. In a self
serving a way. So you know,
I always use the example that
when I used to forge checks,
I needed a Heidelberg printing press.
It took me about 12 months
to learn that press.
That was a million dollar printing
press who is 90 feet long, 18 feet high.
It required three journeymen
operators to operate it.
So I bill scaffoldings on either sides
of the press so I could eliminate the
other two positions.
And because I was a teenager,
I was able to run the length of that
press. But there were color separations,
there were negatives,
there were chemicals you had to work with,
there were plates you had to make.
There was typesetting involved. I today,
one just opens a laptop and decides
to forge counterfeited check.
They first bring up a diagram of a chick
with a little security background in it
and then they go and look on
who's checked in and afford.
So if I'm going to forge for example,
into its check,
I go to the company's website,
capture their logo and put it up on the
corner of the left part of the top of
the check.
I put it in their corporate address,
I might put some stuff in the background
and step and repeat patterns or
whatever it is I'm designing.
And in 15 minutes I have a
four color beautiful check,
prettier than the real check
they use up on my website. Now,
in the old days you to would
have said to me, you know, um,
this check you're printing from Pan
Am I have to admit. Pretty awesome.
It's amazing for color. It's looks
terrific. But uh, let me ask you this.
How do you know where pan and banks,
I have no idea whether it bank,
so I'm just making up a bank's name,
a chase Manhattan Bank,
one Chase Plaza in New York. Yeah. How
do you know what the account number is?
I have no ideas.
I'm just making up a bunch of numbers.
How do you know who the authorized signer
is? I Dunno, I'm just signing somebody,
Joe Black,
whatever name on that check.
But we live in a way too much information
world today. So one side forge,
Intuit's check every forger calls their
victim twice because every four Joe will
tell you a victim will tell me everything
I need to know. So when he calls,
he would have simply said like, just
speak to someone in accounts receivables.
Sure. One moment counts
receivables can help you. Yeah,
I was getting ready to pay an invoice
you sent us, but we prefer to wire you.
The funds just needed wiring instructions.
Yes. So we banked with Bank of America.
Account number is one seven six eight
five three they tell you right on the
phone you can call any company and just
tell him you're going to wire the money.
They're going to tell you where they
bank on one street, their account number.
But you need on the check.
So I captured the bank's logo.
I put it on the checkup at the mic or
line down on the bottom and I hang up and
call back into a corporation
going help you. Yeah,
I like to speak to someone in your
corporate communications shareware moment.
Corporate communications can help you.
Yeah.
I wonder if you'd be so kind of some mail
me a copy of your annual report. Sure.
I'll send you one out today on page three
is a signature of the chairman of the
board, the CEO, the CFO, and the
treasurer, white glossy paper,
black ink camera ready arts scan it,
digitize it, put it on the check.
The technology has made it much,
much easier when we talk about ids.
Making an airline id today would be
very simple with the technology that's
available today.
So all of those things are a lot easier.
And so I used to say that we'd be a
little more difficult for me to get on an
aircraft today posing as a pilot.
But if you ever go to the airport and
watched the crews go through the airport,
they just simply hold up a card and
they go through the airport that anyone
could make that card with today's software
and technology that's available to
anybody. So, uh, technology has
certainly made it a lot easier.
So that's why we're constantly making
technology to counter the use of
technology by criminals and to make it
more difficult for them to convert that
technology into a negative, uh, idea.
And your candid opinion,
did Leonardo Dicaprio and Tom
Hanks do justice t e two urine?
Joseph,
she's respective roles in the movie.
Yeah. You know, I'm, I'm not a
big movie person, so I don't, I,
I've watch very little television.
This is most of my life, not just,
I took up even as a kid,
I didn't watch a lot of television.
I don't watch a lot of television now.
And I certainly very rarely go to movies.
And, uh, so when it was
announced that Leo had,
was the person picked to play the part,
I really knew nothing about them.
My sons weren't too happy that
it was Leo. But, uh, I didn't,
I didn't know anything about them.
So I went to the movies and saw street
gangs of New York and I said to myself,
sitting there, how would this person
portray a person? 16 years old.
He had a beard. He was at the time
he filmed that movie was about 27,
28 years old. Uh, I thought no
one's going to believe this guy 16,
but because I'd never saw the script,
I didn't know if maybe Spielberg was
making the character a lot older and not a
teenager.
Now when the movie came out,
it was quite amazing that Leo starts out
in the film at 14 and he's 16 and he's
18 and he's 21.
Uh,
he is an amazing character actor and he
took the role and he did an amazing job
of playing the role. Tom Hanks, his
character was actually named Joe Shay, s,
h e a who was an Irishman from Boston.
Joe Shay was my supervisor at the
FBI after I came out of prison.
I answered directly to him and I were
friends for 30 years until his death.
I've written five books on crime.
The last book I wrote stealing your life.
I dedicated that book to him
and our 30 year relationship.
But he was an Irishman from
Boston in which Tom Hanks,
he didn't want his real name.
You.
So Tom Hanks used the name of an old
football player and took that name call
hand Randy. But if you are watching the
screen for me it was like watching him.
He looked like him. He sounded
like him. He had his mannerisms.
I did an amazing job.
Uh,
both of them and portraying the pots are
real people that were still living at
that time.
So first of all, as a father, your
statement was just starting to tiering,
totally practical with the Equifax hacks
and yet them hacks that every one in
this room has been probably
affected by one of the other.
Is there anything we can do as citizens
to protect ourselves or is it a lost
cause?
No, I'll tell you what to do. But let
me explain this to you. That is where I,
when I went to the FBI 41 years ago,
I worked undercover for
a long period of time.
Then I went into the field and dealt
with counterfeits and forgeries
embezzlement at financial crimes.
In the last 20 years,
I've dealt with only cyber related crimes.
So I spend most of my time with breaches.
I have worked every breach
back to Tj Maxx 15 years ago,
and this is what I've learned.
First of all, every single breach,
every breach occurs because somebody in
that company did something they weren't
supposed to do,
or somebody in that company failed to
do something they were supposed to do.
Hackers do not cause breaches.
People do.
And every bridge comes down to that.
So in the case of Equifax,
they didn't update their infrastructure.
They didn't fix the patches
it should have put in place.
They were very negligent
and what they were doing.
So the hacker waited for the door to open.
So when you interview a hacker,
the hacker will say to you, look,
I can't get into chase bank.
The truth is they spend about a half a
billion dollars a year on technology.
Every 12 months they spend a half a
billion dollars of their profit on putting
technology in software in their
bank to keep me out. However,
they employ 200,000 people worldwide.
All I have to do is wait for one of
those people to do something they weren't
supposed to do or fail to do
what they were supposed to do,
and that'll open the
door for me to get in a,
when you steal credit card numbers,
like home depot, target Tj Maxx,
that's stealing credit cards and debit
card information that has a very short,
short shelf life, so you have to
get rid of it very, very quickly.
But if I steal your name, your social
security number and your date of birth,
you can't change your name. You can
change your social security number.
You can't change your date of birth.
So those people warehouse that
data for two to three years.
So we won't even see that surface for
at least a couple of years before.
Some of that will start to surface.
The data that was stolen,
whatever number they start with,
I think was 143 million.
Then it became 146 million.
It was a million drivers licenses.
Now it's 10.6 million drivers licenses.
All breaches start with very low numbers
before they let you know the actual
true numbers.
So it's probably about 240 million
pieces of information that was stolen.
But I remind people all the time that
they're going to warehouse that data.
So buying one year credit monitoring
services absolutely worthless because
nothing's going to happen in a year.
And if you really analyze, uh, Equifax,
they were very unethical in what they did.
They thought to themselves,
first of all, they sold a bunch of stock
knowing that it was going to come out.
That was worse. But then they stat there
and said, how do we make a profit from,
this was our mistake,
but how we turn this around into a profit.
So they sat there and said,
what we'll do is we'll offer millions
of millions of people one year of credit
monitoring service for free.
They'll sign up and in a year from now,
we'll simply say,
that data hasn't really surfaced yet.
You need to be enrolled automatically
into our program, which is $20 a month.
So they're going to make millions and
millions of dollars would automatic
enrollment into their, their
program. Um, if you've been a breach,
if you've been a subject of that breach,
there's only two things you can
do and two things. Only one,
you can freeze your credit. Uh,
each state varies about that.
So some states freezing your
credit is free. Other states,
there is a fee associated with it.
Typically $10 to freeze it,
$18 to unfreeze it, $10 to
freeze it. Uh, again, uh,
so for the last two years I've testified
before Congress and you go to my
website at [inaudible] dot com you'll
see me testifying before Congress telling
them that they need to pet a federal law
across 50 states that allow anyone to
freeze their credit at
anytime and unfreeze it.
And any time there should be no reason
that there should be a fee associated
with it because then that becomes a
deterrent to people, uh, actually, uh,
freezing their credit so
you can freeze your credit.
That's one thing you can do and then
you unfreeze it if you need it. Um, if,
if there's not too much of a hassle.
And then the only other thing
is to monitor your credit.
So I've used a credit monitoring service
since 1992 so for about 25 years I've
been using a service,
I think they charged me like $12 a month.
The reason I like it,
I can monitor my own credit.
I don't need them all they've given me
for that $12 is the ability to go on my
keyboard and a few strokes and bring up
my credit reports instantly on my screen
and up on my screen comes all
three reports, Equifax, Experian,
transunion. At the top is my
score for the moment of that day,
what my credit score is
that those three agencies.
Then I can scroll down and look at my
credit and I can say to myself, you know,
I paid this car off like four months ago.
They still show that I
owe money to this bank.
I have correct that and I can go all the
way down and see every inquiry made on
my credit. That's what we
call hard and soft inquires.
And that's your employer checking your
credit, the IRS checking your credit,
your insurance company,
checking your credit or a credit card
you applied for and they're checking your
credit. So I really don't
need them, but for fee, uh,
they're also monitoring my credit as well.
So they're checking my credit and they
letting me know in real time if someone
attempts to use my social security
number to get a job opened,
a bank account or whatever the case
may be. So to me it's worth using that.
Now one other tip I'll give you
is I don't own a debit card.
I've never owned one. I've never
allowed my three sons to possess one,
certainly in truly the worst financial
tool ever given to the American consumer.
So a long time ago I asked
myself a simple question,
how would I remove 99.9% of my
personal liability like that,
where they really don't want to
worry about all these things?
So I use the safest form of payment
that exists on the face of the earth and
that is a credit card, credit card, visa,
mastercard, American Express,
discover card. Not Debit credit,
but credit card.
Every day of my life I spend their money.
I don't spend my money.
My money sits in a money market account.
It earns interest.
Actually nobody knows where it is because
not exposed to anybody to find it.
It's just sitting there. I go to
the dry cleaner, I give him my card,
I pick up the groceries, I
give him my card, I put fuel
in my boat on the weekend.
I use my card. I paid the marina
to keep my boat in the water.
All year long they put the rent on my
credit card. I travel all over the world.
Why wait to get reimbursed?
I use my credit card if I need euro's,
I go to the ATM machine.
I used my credit card.
I'm not gonna use my debit card to get
euros or a pounds and Great Britain.
And every day I use my card and then if
I pay the bill in full or part of the
bill,
my credit score goes up.
So I'm building credit while I'm
using net credit card and if tomorrow,
and I'll do everything to
protect my information,
but if tomorrow someone gets my card
number and charges $1 million on my credit
card by federal law, my liability
is zero. I have no liability.
So yes, I love to shop online.
I don't use a special card,
I just use my credit card if they
don't deliver the merchandise,
if they deliver it and it's broken.
If the host side I went to
is fictitious to begin with,
I have no zero lead zero liability.
When you use your debit card,
every time you reach for your
exposing the money in your account,
the only person's going to get robbed
as you, when you use your debit card,
you could use it for the next 50 years,
20 times a day.
You will not raise your
credit score by that much.
And of course when you use your debit
card you are liable up to a certain amount
and it takes a while in order
to get that debit card fixed.
So when we do post investigations that
breaches and we say to someone on your
incident, what happened?
While I was in target,
but I used a visa card
so I don't know nothing.
I got to cancel my card the next day,
two days later Fedex sent me a new card
and that was the last I heard about it.
What about you?
And I use the debit card there that
took $3,000 out of my checking account.
It took me two months to
get my money back. Why?
They said they were investigating. I
had to pay my rent, had kids' tuition,
everything. I couldn't pay it because
they had my money. So I do it for that.
So I had three sons that went off
to college and I've said to them,
I'm not giving you a debit card.
I've actually applied for a credit
card in your name. So chill card.
Of course you're 18 you have no credit.
So I guarantee the card.
So as a guarantee or of the card,
three things take place. One,
the bill comes to me and I'm
responsible for the bill.
So if you spend a lot of time in the bar,
I'm going to know that too.
And I set the limit on the card.
So whatever I want you to spend each
month is while you're at school,
I'll set that limit. Third, every month
that I pay, the bill goes on your credit.
So by the time you get out of college,
you should be looking at a credit score
of about 800 you want to buy a car,
buy a house, buy a condo. You're
not going to need me to do that.
All three of my sons came out of college
with grades us scores of the round 801
of the best things you can do for your
kids is to teach them to learn to use
credit early on and build credit in their
name. Credit is a very important thing.
30 years ago, it only meant when he
got the car, he got the house. Today,
everything is based on your credit.
The company hires you,
they're going to check your credit.
If your buy auto insurance is going to
check your credit, you buy life insurance,
I'm going to check your credit.
Everything is based on your credit.
So you want to make sure that you
maintain a good credit and it's one of the
best things you can do with your kids.
Question,
I wanted to ask you more about the
FBI specifically and kind of uh,
hiring and how you got in. There is
such an interesting story. Um, you know,
when I was younger I was really interested
in, you know, working for the FBI,
worked in fraud and security.
Um, if my boss is watching,
I'm very happy where I am
right now. Uh, but, uh,
I couldn't believe how difficult it
was to try and get into public service.
I thought, you know, there's, you
know, I was willing to take a pay cut.
I was willing to move anywhere.
I was willing to do anything
and it was difficult.
I mean it was in touch with people at
the FBI and they were super nice and very
helpful, but I just couldn't
believe that, you know,
the background checks and there's no
available jobs and you have to keep
emailing me and Oh you don't have a lot
of Gri. Oh that's not going to matter.
And you know, again, I ended up in
a great spot so I'm happy. But uh,
when people ask me about public service
and working for these organizations,
I really don't have an answer.
The FBI is extremely tough.
We have about 13,000 agents,
uh,
and about 25,000 support people who
support the agent analysts and things of
that nature.
Um,
currently we'd take one in every
10,000 applicants to be an agent.
So it is extremely
difficult to get in the FBI.
So just to share the story with you,
my oldest boy, when he was about 14,
I used to take my kids to the FBI Academy,
which was on a marine military
base in Quantico, Virginia.
Cause I like to shoot guns on the range
and I would take them up there and while
I was teaching class, they would
be out there with the instructor,
a shooting on the range.
And I remember distinctly
coming back off the base,
which takes you about 20 minutes to
get from the academy off to the base.
And when we were riding through
the base, he said to me, no dad,
this is what I want to do. I want
to become an FBI agent. I said,
well that's great son, but
you know, keep that in mind.
And so he graduated from high school.
He said to me,
I really want to become a FBI agent.
I said, that's great. You know,
you've got to go to college. So he
went to school at University of Kansas,
got his undergraduate. He kept, I
always thought he changed his mind. Um,
my wife always had a Christmas
party for all the agents in Tulsa.
We had about 200 FBI agents in the state.
And uh,
every Christmas they would be at our home
with their family and he would go talk
to all of them.
In the special agent in charge
who's in charge of the entire state.
He would say to him, yeah, my
son tried to get in. But uh,
they turned them down and he explained
to him that senator's sons had been
turned down. Former president's
sons had been turned down,
has nothing to do with
anything other than you.
And I kept emphasizing that to him,
but I kept thinking he changed his mind.
So when you graduated from
undergraduate scores said, Sanjay,
I would recommend you go to law school.
I have no desire to be a lawyer. I said,
I understand,
but if you really want to pursue the
FBI and that would put you up a little
higher and the chances of getting
in it went to Loyola School of law,
graduated from law school.
Their bureau requires you pass the bar.
So it took the bar in Illinois,
passed the bar and then he went through
the year long process of the process to
takes to apply to the bureau.
And I got very worried because
I'd say to my wife that, you know,
I'm a little concerned
because first of all,
I don't know if someone in management
would like the fact that my son is an FBI
agent, or maybe someone in
management would look at it and say,
his dad has done so much for him,
for them, we need to look at his son.
It had absolutely nothing to
do with that was all about him.
And I always tell him every day he's
living his life a dream. So He's, he,
he got in, but it is very, very tough.
So when the bureau came to me
and they just a few years ago,
celebrated their hundredth anniversary,
they did a big coffee table book and
they talk about me in there as being the
only person they ever did that with.
Uh,
the whole thing to the bureau back then,
the director was Clarence Kelly,
who was the director of the bureau
at that time. He wanted the ability,
because he could say to me, okay,
you are a lieutenant in the army.
You had been in the army this many years,
you're expertise is this missile.
I need you to learn all of this and two
weeks and I'm sending you to this base
and I want you to find out what's
going on in this particular area.
He knew that no matter what assignment
he gave me undercover, I could go do it.
Whether it was a scientist
at a lab in New Mexico,
whether it was a doctor in a hospital,
he knew that I could get away with it,
make it believe people believe that
I was that person without any doubt.
And that's how they used me.
Um,
I think that was their initial thing.
And then of course when my time was up,
and again, keep in mind that
when I got that offer to me,
it was just an opportunity. I
looked at it, well, opportunity
to get out of jail. I,
I'm not going to sit here and
tell you I was a changed person,
that I was a different person.
And when I went into prison,
I just saw that as an opportunity to get
out of prison. So I was going to do it.
But then I,
you get involved with the men and women
of the FBI who obviously is probably the
most ethical people you'll ever meet in
your life that have tremendous character,
love of country, love of family.
That kind of wears off on you.
And I started to realize that,
you know,
I met my wife and I was becoming
a husband. I take care of my wife,
had take care of children, uh, fatherhood,
all those things is what
really changed my life.
Wasn't that I was rehabilitated
or those things changed my life.
So if it started out
more as an opportunity,
so when my time was over and the court
said his court order is, ceases to be,
he's free to do whatever he wants to do,
I made the choice to stay there only
because I thought that I could bring a lot
to the bureau.
So the bureau was very smart.
They realize very early on that
I wouldn't be accepted very well.
And so there was a great scene in
the movie where Steven Spielberg, uh,
obviously knew that I was very,
very difficult for the agents.
You gotta keep in mind now this is
back when there were no women agents,
no blacks,
no Hispanics,
everybody was white agent and they
either graduated from Harvard or the
graduated from Yale and they all came
from very good families and it was a
totally different
environment 40 years ago.
So they all have really tunnel
vision once a criminal, a criminal.
So they were not very, very happy
with the fact that I came there.
So he showed that scene and me
walking in the office and, uh,
the way people looked at me, that
took years for me to turn that around,
took years for me to
build their credibility.
And of course in the first part
of my career was out in the field,
so as undercover,
so there really weren't dealing with me.
So when I finished working on the cover
that the director then simply said,
you know what?
It needs to go to the academy and teach
class so that every agent who comes to
the academy,
they will,
he will be their instructor in one of
their courses and they will all know him.
So I've taught at the academy
now for well over 35 years.
I taught my son when he went through the
academy, three generations of agents.
And that helped a great deal because
they learned who I was early on,
knew who I was. And that changed a lot
of that. But it took a lot of, lot of,
lot of work to turn that around
and build that credibility.
I'm curious to know whether or not you
continued to fly even after you were
released from jail and working at
the bureau as the movie suggests,
or if that was a bit of Hollywood in now.
You know, when people ask me, um, and I,
I saw the movie in a movie theater.
I've only seen the movie twice.
I've seen that trailer a thousand times,
but I've only seen the movie twice.
So when the media asks me what I thought
about the movie and what was right and
what was wrong, I said, you
know, well, first of all,
I have two brothers and a
sister. He portrayed, portrayed
me as an only child, uh,
in real life.
My mother never remarried.
There's a scene in the movie where
she's remarried as a little girl.
That didn't really happen,
um, in the real life.
I never saw my father after
I ran away, uh, in the movie,
they keep having him come
back to Christopher Walken
and the film was nominated
for the Academy award for
that role as my father. Uh,
that didn't really happen.
I escaped off the aircraft,
but I escaped off the aircraft through
the kitchen gallery where they bring the
food and stuff onto the plane.
And there they had made scape through
the toilet and my wife kind of looked at
me and said, you didn't go through
the toilet. They yes and no.
I didn't go through the toilet.
Um,
so I thought he stayed very
close to the story. But, um,
pretty much all of that was,
he was,
he was very concerned about being
accurate first of all, because it was a,
it was the first time he made a movie
about a real person living second.
The bureau had an information
officer on the set for all the,
all the shooting of the entire film to
make sure that what he said about the FBI
and what comments they made and
all that was accurate. The agent,
there was an agent from our
information officer on the, on the set,
and then of course is he later said,
I really got most of my information from
those three retired agents because they
said they, their notes were
so particular and so accurate.
He said that when I filmed
the scene in the hotel room,
I had scripted it.
And so we're sitting there and I said,
a read me your notes. He said, I
entered the room with my gun pulled,
I heard someone in the bathroom,
I ordered them to come out of the
bathroom and this is what happened.
He basically loved his notes
better than his script.
So he used his notes
for the southern film.
So I thought he did a good job of staying
a very, uh, very accurate. The movie.
I just make a final common to,
uh, having to deal with cyber.
Now I like to write about
crimes in the future. Uh,
so I always used to write to my class
about what will we investigate five years
from now, what will the agent
be doing five years from now?
And unfortunately, um, there's good
news and there's bad news. First of all,
the good news, we will be doing a way
with passwords in the next 24 months.
Passwords will leave the world.
There will be no more passwords.
There is a new technology called
True Sona. That's t r U. S.
O n a stands for true persona.
It is a company in Scottsdale,
Arizona that created a
technology for the CIA,
which we have used now for the last
few years. That technology. Uh,
and I was an advisor on
that technology for the CIA.
So I'm an advisor and bringing
it to the commercial world.
But it was the ability for an agent to
send data back from the fields such as
Afghanistan on their iPhone.
And that Langley would know 100% that
is the agent on the other end to 100%
identify the person on the
other end of the device.
That's a level for security.
So that they basically said,
what if we brought this
to level two security?
And we did away with passwords.
So immediately when they announced that
Microsoft gave them $10 million and said,
I'm in develop it, so Microsoft is
going to use it on all their gaming,
all their access to their computers,
etc. We now have the ability to identify
who the person is on the other end of
that, uh, device. And when you
go to their website at True Sona,
they actually show you how it's done.
So they show you the demo videos there
that are three or four minutes long that
show you how it's done.
And that's great.
Passports or stack of
passwords are stagnant.
They should have been gone long time ago.
It's why we have most of the
problems that we have today.
So it is very important that
we get rid of passwords.
And just in case you didn't know,
if we take a bank like a bank of America,
they spend about $6 million
a month in their call center,
resetting passwords,
cost them $6 million a month.
So that would save that bank $100
million a year to eliminate the use of
passwords.
So that's the good part of it.
And I think that will eventually do
away with social security numbers.
You'll still have a number assigned
to you for the government purpose.
But when I go buy a car,
I go to the doctor,
I don't have to give them a number because
they already know who I am through my
device. I won't have to provide
a social security number.
So I think that's the good part.
But I do believe that cyber it up until
this point in time has been used for
financial crimes or gathering data
and information, which is a value.
What's going to happen is we're going to
see cyber very quickly now turned black.
So we have the ability, as you know, uh,
to basically shut someone's pacemaker off,
but we have to be within 35 feet of them.
We test these device at
Quantico all the time.
So as long as I walk up
within 35 feet of you,
I take control of any bodily
device you have on you.
So if I want to assassinate you, I
want to speed it up, take it down,
I can do that.
But I believe that in five years you'll
be able to do that from 5,000 miles away.
We have the ability,
now that we test that we can
chase a car down the interstate.
We got to get up with them 35 feet of
the vehicle. We take over the vehicle,
we shut the motor off,
we lock the person in the car,
we locked the power windows so they can't
open them and we can turn on their air
bag again.
Five years from now,
you'd be able to do that 5,000 miles away.
So yes,
our electrical grid uses a terrorist tool.
The ability to shut down an entire system,
shut down an entire banking system. Uh,
those are all the things
that unfortunately we'll
be dealing with in the next
four or five a year as cyber starts to
make that turn to the very black side of
cyber, not just about stealing
money, information and data. And, uh,
so that's why we're going to have to
work extra hard to make sure that we go
back to protect our electrical grid.
We,
I always remind people we
have the technology to prevent
most of these problems,
but if you don't use it,
then it's worthless.
And we tend to develop a lot of things.
Uh, I just want to make this emphasis,
do we develop a lot of things
without following them through?
So one thing I've done in the
government over the last several years,
if the government is
going to buy a technology,
they send me to the technology
company and say, try to defeat that.
I could simply go there and see their
technology has one CEO says he plays chess
with you. You tell me you
did this, this, and this,
and then he tells you we have a weakness
right here because I would come in and
do this. So they build a
wall up and then he says, no,
I would still get in here until he says
he can't do it any longer than we know.
We have a good technology,
but very rarely is an,
I did that with true sona when we did it
for the purpose of the CIA. But today,
uh, you, and it tells you on the website
that I advised in that project and why,
how it became down to commercial use.
But today what we have is we
develop things. So we say to you,
here's a device you put in your kitchen,
and then you can talk to her to tell you,
ask what the weather is, what's on TV,
denied. Um, all of that,
that I could easily reverse
that and listen to everything
you say in your house.
There are so many weaknesses in your home.
Your security cameras or access points,
your remote control on your TV,
your Samsung television,
your refrigerator, that
tells you how much, uh, milk,
isn't it?
My thing is I really don't need my
refrigerator to talk to my toaster.
They've gotten along for a long time
without ever having a conversation.
But what happens is we develop something
we get real excited about where I get
this to the marketplace. And sure enough,
we never look at the negative side.
All I tried to say to a technology
company, yeah, this is great.
Now can you take a
little time to just say,
how would someone use this technology
and the negative self serving way so that
we build the block to that before we ever
give it to the public to use it. We'd,
we'd save a lot of problems.
Been absolute pleasure
spending the morning with you.
Thank you very much for coming.
[inaudible].